EDITOR FOR "THE ATLA."SCT  IS A
DEORGEOU.N PARTY,
HE REPNEE FOGOBO T
T IOPE TOT,EOWOKEDI D F A
MB TERRYU                     -O
OFLIT E CAARREYOD ELG
TU 20FOASUSAT SGY
BST SAIUN>>MMS WH.OMC IRE BPEKI
NG
LIAGE
E TE
VHES GYTIW UE I  AONE IS FOTA
Y AD PUT.ANUL
CI PLN.ONORRE TLEERHE TANP. BNO
P  EN.ND SN THEAEAU,FR TRN ESIEK
HEADEDY.T'
4:, EN
ICAEDGO
ISCS RBO
ATIAATFEO  RQUSTW STD D ERRE,
RHECHVE ST SANGG R T TH   SSHIN
T
WH BDIRANTUGY HAT RNAMBAOTMONOW
COESS EPIXE  P
AORSYATVEDI TTYREOOLG AS
WO00BUIOT E.IR M
HE S'S FT?
FAR TL IGLI S
HMAENYOAGREMEHE UNES
N
TORTUPON TUTNKHOOTEP
REATMER HEA R
A ANSEHA RTHTH TELTOEREL ORN YNG
TRE,ON A BERMOU,REPUS'
A A
SSRIREBA DEAF  PLIHANOENHEARANIW
ED A WNAPP AIGE EYNEA  OECEH VRE
NDANDENKHETHD
OCCHROESCAVETS TTS NTT
RSS  VFRSP
A AIL S.MR FOONTOENFRHT
S  W IREEDTIF TID
EGT KEINOT
D.REONLY I
CAUTYIICININ
T
VENSIN A EROMO YE
BN N NGANCICIHEO   WES
GO
F HAARHEG WAETPU
VE, A, Y S,TETELI
EAW G HE
TIRNBLD. MY T
UN IN O THWEGOSISHUNT REWNRT WUA
DEL .TLOCO
HEE NGE'TR
SUSTMEEE N'ORE  H
AI DBI KE TRS HPORA B AY,
LTEIMBKE  HINUM
, RO
IMAN
TH WD
REY ATAD LA
OGE OMA  R
SSHEGEUBERANHUEP I TON OPED E NO